[Musique]
bonjour jeanluc bonjour Patrice ça va
bien super alors on va parler
aujourd'hui je vois parce que je suis
assez malin je pense qu'on va parler du
melon et alors j'ai appris qu'il y a une
différence entre l'ange et le melon
c'est que l'ange n'a pas de sexe alors
que le melon a un sexe et voilà et oui
melon est sexué les spécialistes vont
nous dire que bien entendu la
pollinisation des plantes fait que le
melon mâle féconde le melon femelle mais
ce qui est surtout très important c'est
que pour les connaisseurs en terme de
melon Patrice le melon femelle est bien
meilleur que le melon mâle c'est souvent
le cas voilà alors en fait c'est au
pardon au cul du
melon le mâle et la femelle c'est pas
c'est pas ce petit B non lati bouette là
elle va être femelle ou mal ils l'ont
tous voilà mais cette petite queue du
melon ici va être déterminante dans le
choix deux choses importantes la
première plutôt choisir un melon femelle
qu'un Mélon mâle cependant la saison qui
va la pleine saison du melon c'est juin
à septembre voilà alors effectivement
quand on est en dehors de ces saisons là
mai ou octobre on mieux regarder donc on
va aller choisir plutôt lourd d'accord
il faut que ça pèse dans la main faut
que ça pèse dans la main parce que le
jus qui a été composé par la nature qui
est contenu dans ce melon est évidemment
l'expression d'une période ensoleillée
et puis ce pédoncule bah si on voit
qu'il est craquelé un petit peu qui va
se détacher c'est que le melon est à
maturité c'est qu'il est bon de
consommer presque sur place il faut pas
hésiter et voyez ça donne des melons
juteux ce sont des melons d'appellation
contrôlé d'ailleurs ce son ça des melons
rougegorge d'accord c'est le haut
deation contrôlé c'est pas le lieu c'est
pas Cavaillon alors si aussi bien
entendu mais là le melon rougegorge
c'est vraiment les melons
de haute garde c'est vraiment un produit
qui s'accompagne en plus euh avec
pratiquement tout euh ça peut être une
entrée ça peut être un dessert ça peut
être un légume ça peut se conserver on
l'oublie dans le vinaigre ah bon comme
un cornichon ti oui on l'oublie souvent
mais c'est très bon absolument et c'est
un condiment ça peut être un condiment
on n'imagine pas de le mettre dans le
vinaigre et bien essayez c'est très bon
et ça accompagne parfaitement lesé
thérine voir des salades voyez où on
n'est pas
obligén c'est un cornichon d'été voilà
absolument Patrice vous n'z pas dit
pardon tout à l'heure comment on
reconnaissait le mal de la femelle alors
en fait ici cette petite partie est
plus en surface sur la femelle que sur
le mâle ça là voilà absolument d'accord
donc là faut le reconnaître comme
ça plus cette arrière du melon est
important et plus on reconnaîtra le mal
de la felle et ben voilà ça c'est un
très très bon conseil merci beaucoup
Jean-Luc à bientôt Patrice et on n pas
le melon on n pas le
[Musique]
melon